some girls like working out and it
flashed and it was like a naked butt
naked picture of her and it goes better
pause quick I block like 20 people a day
they did nothing wrong to me I just
think their content is garbage oh
why do you pop up on my page I block
them instantly it's always girls that
are doing this
if you look at the mirror they're butt
naked showing their whole ass or
showing their whole vat like
completely butt naked and go how
do you post this and I naked pictures is
sick
I'm not saying you're gross I'm saying
for principal reasons you need to be
blocked how the can you post your
bare body and I can't say the
words 1200 milligrams I block you for
principles
you